daily mail says alex jones is worth 270
million dollars forensic accountant
tells court true worth of infowars
founder i'm wondering how much of this
is just bluster nonsense and they're
saying this so they can rip the you know
just gut the company because if you come
out you say he makes 800 000 a day which
was like one day it was like two days or
something like that and then you claim
he's worth 270 million you justify a
massive hit settlement right of course
yeah right or judgment yeah and then
what if it turns out he actually just
doesn't have anything i mean because i
wouldn't be surprised i guess he's
divorced you know he's an ex-wife or
something like that
well like why would he keep 270 million
dollars in his bank account like well i
mean when some when a forensic
accountant says something is worth
something what they mean is the sale
price right like the the best market
price like i mean i just built a company
that's worth you know i don't know in
the top actually i know exactly what
it's worth it's worth a lot
not 270 million but like let's say the
company's worth i don't know 60 million
right that means that's the sale price
yeah we're not making 60 million a year
even top line right like it's 60 million
is the cost of the asset not what the
value it produces i'd i'd love to see
the financials i'd be shocked if he
someone said he's doing 60 million a
year now he's doing 180 pre-banned from
youtube and everything right
pre-platforming yeah so 60 would make
sense that's that's
that's 60 down they the the guy
apparently says that jones he says
records show that jones withdrew 62
million dollars for himself in 2021 when
default judgments were issued in
lawsuits against him they said he was
also funneling 11 000 a day into one of
his shell companies after he was alleged
to have defamed parents and victims of
sandy hook uh
i don't know man
they say uh apparently this guy is
saying that he rakes in about 70 million
dollars a year from infowars the
question is is that revenue or profit
it's got to be top line there's no way
that's profit like of course they're
going for the bigger number right of
course yeah so if 70 is the top line and
it depends how you structure this
company right
and most that money is on supplements
right that's the presumption is that the
vast majority of that is supplement
sales
well so the question is how
now if he has some deal with an external
company he may only be taking 20 30
percent of that you know and so if it's
i'm gonna totally make up numbers if
it's 50 million from supplement sale
from supplement sales his cut may only
be 20
they brought this up in the trial they
asked they said that
jones testified his profit margin was 20
to 40 percent make sense and then they
said in a text message someone said a 70
profit he's like well that's not correct
well on the media company though maybe
right you run a media company you could
run a media company if you once you get
some scale
you can run that pretty profitably right
youtube's a crazy business businessman
if you if you spend money one time on a
camera right and then uh
start working yeah it can be 9 500
profit exactly right so so it depends he
could be 70
on his subscription model right yeah but
then the supplements it all depends i
doubt he's running a supplement company
he's probably got like partners in fact
i could probably figure it out i'm
pretty sure i'm pretty sure he has like
three companies right i could be wrong
and um like one of them does supplements
right and then he contracts them yeah
not other people who do the fulfillment
and everything i'm sure oh yeah like he
doesn't yeah
he said that the stuff he gets is the
same stuff as like gnc and whole foods
exactly so so he's probably making it's
almost like an affiliate deal right so
he's probably making 20 on that so like
you look at a blended average i could
totally see it 25 30
on the whole company
70 on media you know when the news came
out i got a whole bunch of messages and
people tweeting at me being like alex
jones
two hundred to eight hundred thousand
dollars per day
people's people just sent me a message
being like 160 million dollars just like
that dude is making an insane amount of
money but here's what i here's what i
think if it's true my question is why
wouldn't he be spending it on
crazier things he has a nice house in
austin i know that it's expensive yeah
but i mean if you're making that much
money if he really took 62 million for
himself i mean there's a certain point
there's this tomb there's like you can
buy anything you know i mean he could
buy stuff or he can he we've already
said he has two children he can use it
to create generational wealth i mean
theoretically if he managed it correctly
they could really support generations to
come i'm just saying if it's true that
he made that much money where's the
shenanigans from alex jones you know
like we we put a 96-foot billboard of
our rooster roberto junior up right from
times square
and uh i'm they banned james lindsay so
i'm like do i got to put up with james
lindsey
that's my thing now i think so so we're
gonna look into it cause i'll totally do
it and we don't make nearly that much
money like we have enough to do these
these funny things with yeah but
that's not who alex is and it's it's not
who anybody is that's the problem
yeah just me i guess there's some well
but where's elon to just like i'm going
to buy every billboard in times square
you want the real answer on why i'll
tell you this is going to sound super
weird because like when i was when i
first started writing and i was like the
og on the internet and i was making a
little bit of money i was just making no
money and like a lot to me was like oh
dude i made 10 grand this month i'm like
this is amazing like this is more than i
could ever spend that's what i was
single and all you know
and so like i did like uh dumb ass [ __ ]
with my money too here's what happens
though man as you like i'm 46 now i was
26 when i started writing
as you
uh kind of as you accrue wealth and
power
and relationships the more time you
spend
doing dumb ass [ __ ] that draws attention
to yourself unless that's your business
model the uh the weaker it gets real
power wants to be invisible right and
real wealth wants to be unseen you know
like i i have a decent ranch in dripping
springs like 50 acres you know it's fine
right i one of my good friends has a 350
acre ranch on barton creek it dude
switch was so expensive it's so nice and
if you saw the gate to it you would
think like it was some ranch shackle
like meth lab like around here like you
would never he doesn't want anyone to
know that he has this insane ranch with
like that's god i mean like he doesn't
want
i've found it's it's happened to me too
i've gotten more experience or more
conservative and less like oh let's do
cool ridiculous stuff just because as
i've gotten older and richer but it's
it's i get that
for sure but the question is like alex
jones is the culture warrior
yeah but that's see but what he cares
about
right like you know pretty well he i
think what
he's one of those dudes i think he
actually believes he's doing the right
thing and he actually cares about truth
and he that dude's been ringing the
epstein belt for 15 years i agree which
is which is why i'm like if he actually
had this money wouldn't he be doing
substantially more to push this stuff
see this is what i don't get and look it
really does come down to my my personal
world view versus what other people
think or see right it's just that simple
some people make 62 million dollars then
they're like better put that in my trust
for my kids or something like that
me i'm like
you know we got michael malus luke
rudkowski up on billboards in times
square
because they've been on this show i
respect them but i also think it's
important to have their presence be
expanded and i got to tell you the the
one one of the things i'm most excited
for was that we got luke rodkowski do
you know luke
i'm most excited about getting him up in
time square on multiple billboards
because he's the guy who only a couple
years ago like walks up to donald donald
rumsfeld and starts questioning him one
of the few people who's gotten in the
face of these ceos and these big
corporations and i was like it's going
to be the funniest thing in the world
when his face is looking down on times
square and then this guy who actually
had the balls to go and question all
these people is going to be you know of
significant influence that's what i want
to see it doesn't it you know it
benefits us because it's a tim cast ad
right of course but i'm looking at this
like
if we make enough money how can we have
a bigger impact on just making things
better dude that's awesome and i'm with
you i'm just gonna and i'm not arguing
this is right i'm just not only because
i've seen my i know a lot of people who
are pretty
uh well known i've see i've come up with
them and i've seen the change in them
when people have something to lose
right like
they when someone's young and just
starting off or just got momentum and
you don't have anything to lose man it's
easy to do risky [ __ ]
as you as you
have more have more people depending on
you as you accrue more most people
become more risk averse and quite
frankly like when you start having a lot
of money and you're able to turn let's
call it a youthful idealism into reality
you start being an actual threat to
people in power oh yeah and then when
that lens turns on you and i've had it
turned on me not quite the way alex did
but it i've it's a lot dude it's a lot
and so like again not not saying he
should or shouldn't be a certain way i'm
just saying there's a reason that very
few people retain their idealism through
wealth and power
yeah you know i'm not trying to single
out alex on this one there's a ton of
wealthy people who speak up and then
seemingly don't do all that much but you
know there are a lot of people you'd
think should do more but do a lot i'm
not gonna name anybody but they're
they're powerful individuals who fund
stuff
and then i just you know but my question
is
we've got cultural problems in this
country we've got cultural stagnation
cultural decay we got a culture war and
that's because there is no
forward-facing no brazen no adventurous
no heroic no challenge no
figurative threat to the to to you know
no one uh ruffling the feathers up or
anything like that i think we need to we
need to get more people to figuratively
throw a pie that's what i keep saying to
people i'm like dude what did you do you
made how much money did you make this
year and then you put it you bought what
like you did nothing with it mm-hmm so i
don't know man um
i i would be happy living in a van down
by the river and everybody knows that's
true and that's why i'm like okay let's
put up these billboards and just keep
doing this this crazy stuff
because i want to see things get better
i want i want to see a positive impact i
want to see positive cultural change i
don't see a benefit
or a point
to just having 60 million dollars in a
trust sitting somewhere i totally agree
with you i'm i'm on board
let me tell you two things one i don't
mean this in a negative way i've seen it
happen to me just wait until you have a
wife and kids and you have like real
money and that'll happen soon enough it
might take 10 years or whatever but like
it'll happen but what is what is real
money
i mean like
whatever you consider real money to be
you're you're like you have that plus a
zero
so you mean like there comes a point
where you're like
i thought i was rich but now wow yeah
but um
no no i'm i
your views are going i don't mean this
like oh you're gonna learn about the
real world no no no dude you might still
be super idealistic and doing all kinds
of cool stuff i hope you are that's
awesome just understand like it's it's
very easy from a certain position to say
well that person in that position should
be doing that they have all kinds of
forces working on them that that are
almost impossible to imagine until you
get there and i'm telling you someone
who started with nothing and went
through all these phases i just kind of
feel like it's uh
at every step of the way
you know i'll tell you this story i
remember watching a video about climate
change activists or something they went
they went to like an oil executive's
house yeah and then they were protesting
in there and then he comes out right and
he sits down with him and he was like
say it all right and then they started
yelling at him and he just sat and
listened and then they were like what do
you have to say for yourself and he's
like i completely agree with everything
you said like we're trying to figure
this out and then he he rebutted with
100 plus million people 200 million
people driving cars every day and
they're telling us we have to do this
and so we're trying to figure out how do
we be better stewards of the earth when
you have 200 million people who are
making demands and if you stop producing
the oil then the government comes and
says why did you stop people are
screaming at us and demanding you do it
so you can't just the point was
this dude at the highest level was like
supposedly the villain and he's like but
i agree with you the problem is the
machine is controlling you
so my thing is like then you've got to
just one day wake up and be like i don't
care for the machine
so you know look my i'm saying
that's easy to say yeah but but 60
million dollars come on somebody hold on
how did you get me defending the machine
i hate them like i am the anti-machine
no here's here's the thing i i
fundamentally fundamentally agree with
your premises the one thing i would
i i want to go back to what you said
before for a second when you were like
people need to do this and do that you
know why i think so many people are so
what does malice call it black pilled
right now is because he says people are
are we are no he's white pill but so
many other people
uh because i think the old american
story broke
right and whenever it broke and however
it broke it's broken it's shattered no
one believes it anymore and no one has
replaced that story right and so that
most people are followers you know not
good or bad they just are and right now
the dominant narrative in america is a
very toxic destructive death cult like
whatever
crt or wokism or that whole
conglomeration of narratives are
horribly anti-human and depressing and
toxic and there has been no narrative to
replace it and it's not we're not going
back to old school american
exceptionalism that's not going to work
do that story
right or wrong it's broken and no one
believes it anymore so what's the next
story what's going to replace that i
don't have the answer yeah transhumanism
people becoming cyborgs we've already
got our phones look what we're doing now
with zero money we're displaying to 100
million people i think
your your point is uh uh simply put
i think most people are looking at the
culture right now and thinking
i have nothing in common with these
people right so i won't do anything for
them what's the point and so you know i
describe it as like
our government for instance the titanic
hit the iceberg
they saw it happen everyone else is
clueless they're abandoning ship but
they're still they're stealing the
silverware everything they can
they got their their their vests loaded
up with with silverware and they're in
the lifeboat lowering it down just a
routine test just gonna go talk we'll be
right back and you're like where are you
going with all that really expensive
stuff in that boat yeah that's what i
see happening in this country i agree
but i think that's a good explanation
for why we don't see more people i think
a simple explanation for you know alex
jones is probably that
they're that's top line they're claiming
he has more money than he really does
yes because because alex i've seen his
tank i've seen the stuff he does when he
drives that armored vehicle around he
does spend a lot of money on this stuff
but i'm just wondering you know
for how many culture warriors there are
um i shouldn't say i'm wondering i get
exactly what you're saying i think most
people have a large self-interest
and then a smaller
altruistic interest but with no story
a lot of people will put resources
behind a great movement
there's no great movement right now i
know a ton of people
with like stupid stupid money private
plane private island money not like me
like way more than me and they're all
sitting on it because even like people
who want
you know why they don't know what to do
with it and i don't just mean they don't
know how to invest it or they don't know
how to make money because there's plenty
there just care about making money right
but the ones who want to do the right
thing who would love
to to to back the next thing or help
i
i know they don't know what to do i know
you are correct because i have seen
very wealthy people talk about these
issues and they are clueless as to
what's causing it utterly and i used to
be a fundraiser like i remember when you
would get people who would come in and
say like i just i want to do something
i'm not sure and they are very
susceptible to whoever messages them i
mean that's what a major gift opera
officer for a non-profit or a school
does they court people who need
direction how to donate their money a
really good example i think is look at
all of the twitter alternatives that
exist
like okay you got gab you've got getter
you've got truth social you've got
parlor
this is a really good example of i think
what the issue is is that people are
like hey twitter's banning conservatives
and people who are challenging the
establishment so let's make a new
twitter and the actual reality is the
technology and the platform is not the
problem the problem is culture the
cultural dominance and the issue that
the people who run these companies like
twitter they are ideologically driven
100 so when you have a group of people
who are well off not particularly
ideological driven ideologically except
they support free speech they don't know
how to solve the problem they say let's
make a new twitter congratulations
nobody uses it there's already a place
people are fighting with each other and
arguing what you need is like an elon
musk to buy the twitter that's a clever
move but but what i said to some of
these people when i'm sitting in these
meetings i'm like you guys you really
don't get it it's a cultural problem you
need someone like michael malus
you need you need a masterful troll to
create a cultural shift through a large
cultural shock which is why you know i
mentioned
my view on things is
maybe maybe where i'm getting things
wrong is people absolutely are spending
money but they just don't they're not
addressing the culture problems no
they're not they're spending money on
technology they're spending money on new
companies or new buildings or things
like that or stuff but thinking this is
a positive move to change things
meanwhile the culture keeps churning in
the woke cult direction yes yeah
about two years ago two and a half years
ago i really kind of started to figure
this out and i'll tell you what i'm
doing now
like
and i don't talk about it a whole lot
publicly just because i'm kind of at the
beginning stages but i've you know i
moved to a like bought a land moved to a
ranch right but not just like i'm gonna
go be a prepper homesteader like we're
definitely homesteading but i bought in
a place that a bunch of other people i
knew were there and then a bunch of
other people came we started our own
school and now like almost everything i
do now is i do one of two things either
i think very very locally like where am
i buying my stuff right like where am i
getting
water power food etc like who am i uh um
who am i buying from right
are they in my community um how am i
supporting my community who am i
bringing into my community how are we
connecting uh how are we interfacing
with each other
not to like have some
you know some island or some cult
somewhere i mean we live in texas we're
a town in texas there's a bun but like
i want to think as much as possible
locally i don't i i think
that if there's gonna be a thread
that is a true counter culture thread
it's gonna be around
think about how disconnected and
detached everyone is from each other the
opposite of that is not just
interpersonal it's low as much as
possible local i mean obviously i can't
get my oysters locally i live in
you know the desert but like as much as
i can i want to interfa and know my
neighbors and interact with them and buy
from them and sell to them and create
our own economy we have our own school
we literally just started a school we
got 80 families and 100 something kids
yeah that's great like it just i mean
because
who wants it public schools are disaster
yeah you know like who wants to send
their kids to
i don't even get you blocked on youtube
but to to public schools now right like
uh and so i i
that idea has just started on some some
with a lot of people i don't i think
that's going that's going to be one of
the main ideas but not the only one you
know i i don't know what it's if i knew
i'd be i'd be shouting it from the roof
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there is a massive library
to check out so again go to timcast.com
or tune in monday through friday at 8pm
and we'll see you all there
you